oh yeah oh there it is I think we're
actually working do you wanna okay you
know i'm looking i see i see the the
audio heartbeat that you might do a show
let's do a show you got your uh your
hard drive plugged in yeah I do I'm not
a spate I don't know here's the thing
between my phone in my computer I
literally will get a brand-new three
days later I'm on face well because they
all sync up and all the other it just
makes copies of everything what do I
have I I don't even know what I have
inside this thing that I'm storing I try
and it's always other it's not it's
nothing more than like you have 475
gigabytes of other that's what it says
when you get diagnostic yeah there's
like you have nothing and then nothing
and then the rest of it is other note
what's other let's I have 15 photos like
yeah cuz I've taken out a lot of photos
I've taken out i'm actually doing okay
on storage i'm not trying to brag gosh
that's a hot a rag that's better than
usual your tumblr brag my tumblr broke
what does that thing called it's not a
not making i'm not making cocktails dude
it's my travel my travel mug sorry
welcome to how we're gonna say i'm brian
Irwin I'm John travel mug Huck oh please
don't I want to know why get myself a
nickname I knew people in college it
gave themselves nickname yeah myself and
ignite first up rule number one never
never sell [ __ ] man you cannot give miss
you can't walk in the adorable law but
you cannot do we all know the person
that did but I you got to be real
careful with that because with the beard
you could actually have a success called
travel mug hug good sear it you be
selling travel mugs that guy with the
travel mug cart and then he tells jokes
on the side every people people have
that people use the hook a part of their
name and that great success but I'm so
just I've never I've ever done that I've
never done like a hawk you t-shirt or no
its traffic la oh that's what that's
where it'll be a cartoon picture of you
on a t-shirt holding a mug which is like
trouble is a little bit bigger than then
like regulars I like it
little 7-11 sighs yeah big gulp travel
mug oh yeah they go cuz that's hilarious
right guys if you want to invest in this
project send check or money order to p.o
box they still do those commercials I
don't know but we should start doing it
and see if anyone sends us anything
probably not that's why they stopped
doing those commercials so do you think
people would you guys send us stuff if
we are we talking to you right now
talking to the people listening you know
that I can answer right now I'm
expecting it's the first time ever done
that I just want to make sure I want to
make sure you rec'd I directly addressed
the our listenership okay that's okay
back asking the question that's the
thing yeah well would you guys if we had
a p.o box would you mail us like artwork
that you drew of us from pictures you
found online I don't know about we'll
find out wait what if we had a p.o
bottom exactly what you want don't ask
just say this what you would like and
see if anybody responds to draw draw
pictures of me and Brian start again but
be more like kind like but because you
can't hey I'm [ __ ] you get now your
kind of people morning put that bomb
down I'm talking to you draw pictures of
me and Brian we want artwork for the
show but we need to know that you'll do
that so respond to us in the email and
then if you like it will set up a p.o
box I would not miss guys I bet nobody
responded either one of us on Facebook
yeah why I talk to my people oh I'm
gonna have I'm gonna give people okay
I'm gonna get people yeah I too much
interaction with the public now I'm
gonna get some people yeah you noticed
and around me so that other people can't
see me we do you think of my fake vomit
and poop it's pretty sweet huh this
looks like salsa by the way this looks I
was like it may have been sauce all over
the table then I was like oh I bet
that's supposed to be and then at first
I was like did the cat just throw up for
like that was a split second I was like
it's too shiny yeah I with the young
kids have definitely we're in the midst
of comedy high jinks in the house they
place this around and yeah and it's
always the same it's like dad dad the
dog pooped on the floor all they call
you okay because we've done this for
four days straight so and I and then I'm
like okay I'm kind of being a douche
like an adult douche like this is what
they want to do this is simple joys and
humor for that exactly you gotta repeat
repeat repeat yeah
Pete repeat so oh my god the poop oh my
god the poop oh my god the poop over and
over and again they're just gonna be
like oh my god dad said poop holy [ __ ]
well the best actually shits what they
hear more than poop here but you uh no
need to talk about this stuff this is a
tree will share with our guests cuz I
gave him a special poop too but you said
there was something that you wanted to
tell me ah you're handsome dude Oh two
pieces of big news big nose DUI let's
bring you live sake news stuff duh you
know I don't know big news it did it did
it did it let's bring our guests and
then we can talk about is ok you can
share in the glorious news our guest
it's fun don't talk about introduced us
so close to our so cool so good our
guest today ranked in the 800 s in the
world of comedy of tennis okay uh
hilarious stand-up comic television host
comments section my pick to win this
entire hosting game mm-hmm uh Michael
Kosta everybody thank you which part of
that introduction are you most proud of
well i think i think that introduction
you stated at my ranking and the world
in tennis I mean that was you know
eleven years ago but it would be awesome
if I was still ranked that um I'm off
the computer now how do you you look
it's not easy to be right just so we're
clear it doesn't matter whether it's 800
away i mean it's it's by far like the
thing the most difficult thing i've done
but what also is funny about it is when
i tell people what my and that was the
highest that was ever ranked that's my
career high what was was when was the
exact number 864 okay when I tell people
my greatest in my opinion life
achievement they always just laugh and
they go like I don't even know they
ranked that many you know it's like yeah
you know that was kind of proud of that
for a second yes so that cuz it's it's a
worldwide rain this isn't like 800 in
Detroit right no no you weren't in Saudi
at all no no no what I also remind
people is like I was ranked that number
for like five days you know and then I
went back down like the two thousand
what I wanna see how was what wasn't
ranking was alive a lot of questions
happening at once I mean
which caused the ranking with what's
what I will say it was there a specific
event that you won that that puts you in
and then you'll also in tennis you
accumulate points every time you win a
match you accumulate points and at that
word her career towards for one calendar
year okay you accumulate as many points
so if you win the US Open you get a
thousand points okay I was winning one
round at a UH synonymous to a double a
single a baseball level tournament I
would I would beat John Huck in that
tournament I would get one point so I
had my total amount of points was like
17 ATP points and again if you win one
round at a Grand Slam you get like 300
points so I mean it's just like you know
minor league baseball players what do
they make a week like a hundred and
nineteen dollars yeah man it's not good
not good i mean i remember one one time
I lost in the second round in a
tournament in Zihuatanejo Mexico which
is the city where Annie Dufresne escapes
prison to in the Shawshank those were
the kind of cities i was playing uh I I
made a hundred and nineteen dollars in
my hotel hotel bill was like 1,200 you
know it you'll be compensated now you
all of your travel you don't you is on
you you get like equipment and stuff but
that's the sponsor thing so depending on
your level of sponsorship some of that
stuff will be taking care of it at the
level you are at it like some you know I
always it kind of sucks being for the
United States sometimes because we're so
dense and population that if I was from
like a tight like if I was like from
Ecuador you know I would get like
Ecuadorian Tennis Federation money great
unity like it would be a lot of money
but it would still be they have a
federation yeah you know every stipend
for you to travel a good hotel yeah and
in in you would sleep would like the
hottest Ecuadorian girl which is still
shatter that Hooper had to provide yeah
and so like in the States I was nine
hundred the world in tennis and I was
still like a hundred in the United
States you know was that my throat or
that that was no what about was amazing
though that was your throat getting I
yeah at that the special skills the
first time our guest has died during a
brief RIT Michael costs everybody off uh
oh man well so we'll get back to thank
you for having me thank you Ben Tennyson
sexiiii i'm intrigued of the the the the
stillness of the struggle of we only
that basically said why anyone want to
do it but yeah and we've talked to
athletes uh mopeds potentially to and
anthony lobbies and was in the NFL for
five seasons and while that's that's
done now he's in every other commercial
you see and in every other now he's
diabetic with two hippie place actually
he went that's why you got out of spires
you saw his relatives who like played 12
seasons and couldn't get off couches and
their knees were blown out i just saw
this biz bears uh duh 30 for 30 and jim
mcmahon starts each day doing puzzles so
save as I mean to save his brain and I'm
like he's either a genius or it's
already happened you don't I mean he's
either increasing and the fridge you see
the fridge and that I didn't abated
house on a chair drinks 18 packs of beer
uh loud cuz he hit with a cane that's
what he does the river sad really sad
story I'm not laughing at Jim McMahon
abs this is its just oh no III think he
actually impressed me that he that he
was fighting quote-unquote fighting
potential brain loss well they had the
new word puzzles in like crossword
puzzles do have sharper brain yeah but
have you heard his have you seen the
clip of him online like you know he's
got the light sensitivity is not a
[ __ ] he has to wear size one size
gonna get huge headaches yeah yeah um
but online he was like he actually
talked about specifically how the NFL
well you know why is marijuana on the
band cyrax letter X it's on the banned
substance list because they don't want
you to medicate with marijuana because
marijuana is a pain reliever and it's a
natural pain reliever whereas what the
NFL does is get in cahoots with the drug
companies and just push pills down at
him all day long so it's just like if
whatever ails you they got a pill for it
you know I mean I love that he just took
that on I agree and what we have to lose
those awful as he's not gonna get into
the Hall of Fame yeah you know what I
mean yet no I love that he was like you
know
oh he goes if I had a gun I would have
killed myself and speculum sorry but
sports hero saying that but it did and
the rule is that sounds that is very
valuable information and that says a lot
about why maybe people who play in the
NFL shouldn't have guns yeah you know
I'm yet like there's also that interview
uh I just applaud Sports Illustrated for
actually like just say you know airing
the ESPN would never hold on you ever
you cannot go again ed NFL recipe and
that that's it that's ESPN all they do
is beat off non-stop to the NFL and the
NBA that's all they care about they will
shove it up your butt holes they don't
care they're the worst they are a
terrible sports network as as a tennis
fan you know I'll watch like a member
federer nadal had that epic five-set
Wimbledon final it was like seven hours
okay it was like the greatest match of
all time and sports centers like the
greatest tennis match of all time here's
match point okay LeBron getting off an
airplane I'm like a horrorshow one point
yeah of that they don't it doesn't
that's why now you have the tennis
network so you watch that as I watch MLB
Network in the HL now there's plenty of
options yeah that's it but that's what's
what's funny is that for both you know I
used to put ESPN on the ESPN on in the
morning yet stay on all day yeah that's
why I got all my information I know like
your news yeah yeah um all right sorry
so we talked about sports a little bit
there but no I two pieces of great news
ah yes your great news yes first piece
of great news um a friend of mine went
to prison for fourteen years a while ago
was didn't see this one coming ended up
on the deferment on the on the commuted
sentence list that Obama just put okay
alright next Wednesday he was supposed
to go out November of 2017 Wow because
obama uh these are these official pardon
no not part these aren't pardons these
are commuted senses so he sells to come
on go to a halfway house but he got 14
years for selling drugs to an undercover
cop oh wow but he was completely set up
by the system if that makes sense yeah a
guy came to him as like hey man my
friend was like it was like carlito's
way yeah he was like hey I thought you
were my buddy was like I thought you
were in jail he's like no man I got out
I fought that case I got out here
so they hung out for a while and then
like within a week this guy was like hey
man I need five pounds of meth yeah and
this guy was like dude I am NOT a meth
dealer like he dabbled in some weed you
know what I mean yeah he was a and he's
just a genuinely nice guy one of the
nicest dude you'll ever meet so this guy
just kept flashing cash like the same
thing happened my brother with the car
parts thing a long time ago but sky just
kept flashing money and finally this my
friend was like okay I'll make a couple
phone calls and of course he they got
you found it right away and this guy had
it said he could pinpoint he could find
he could get the LAPD the the meth
kingpin of Los Angeles and he set my
friend up to be that guy so that my
friends so like had to go and was like a
first-time offense was a non-violent
offense and for some reason the judge
was like you give 14 years well that's
the problem with all of these that their
nonviolent and I do understand if you're
if you're standing in front of a middle
school you know time making kids try
drugs it's like I took that that's a
different thing the different deal this
is so he's gonna be out yeah so he gets
out next how long was he in uh he was he
did about about 10 wow he's got each is
not just fill with bitterness and hatred
and come out and just start murdered
right that's all things I'm concern yeah
all this incarceration in the first
place for a non-violent what ends up
happening these people is you go in
nonviolent you come out no wants to hire
you you get angrier and angrier screwed
in the first place even if you weren't
screw fine you make a mistake but you
you sit for so long and you're you're
seen assert your out that society treats
you a certain way you're kind of screwed
for the rest of your life yeah but and
so the leg up thing is just gone they be
the by the way everyone hates the fact
that Obama is doing this but when I say
everyone certain types of people have
already said great yeah thanks Obama
thanks for bringing out all the bad guys
as if no other you ever done this report
from determined including like triple
the amount of Pardons like of any other
president ever like it so again but this
is so you know I mean less this is good
news because if if if people that are
getting out or anything like my friend
if they're even like half the human
being this guy is then yeah they don't
deserve to be in there for that long and
also to be clear they didn't just
blindly start releasing people they they
looked into it and no
the release this guy did 10 15 years for
it come on dude like this everyone
involved in his case that went to prison
is either out or dead at this point Wow
like you know he he deserves to be out
um so anyway that's a super happy yeah
he gets out next wednesday i'll be on
the show next thursday yeah yeah you
know we will definitely have i've
visited a bunch of times about
podcasting um yeah it's all you talked
about the whole time you were there name
is it you visit him is he was he in a
Illinois incarceration no Terminal
Island he was he's down by long beach it
was an island isn't it yeah well not
really it's more like terminal isthmus
yeah connected piece of land that's
scary but um but yeah I went and visited
and it was it was a it's not the orange
jumpsuit I'm gonna shank you prison it's
the beige dickies work boots we play on
a softball team prison okay that makes
any sense like federal no because I
don't have read that familiar with I
don't have too many points of reference
well I'll tell you this there's a lot of
wire there's a lot of razor wire
everywhere uh and it was uncomfortable I
always had to bring [ __ ] quarters
because that's all the vending machines
took you can't bring paper money in I
thought you meant to just throw on the
ground and watchful chase after right
now because it was like you gotta buy
him food when you get this a honey bun
you wanna the honey buns out do Code Red
likes always this garbage he was like
when I get out of here I'm never using a
microwave again ever eating out of a
vending machine again oh those are good
things and then I was like do some
push-ups they get their own food these
those are their treats if you will if
you have cash you can get these other
things is that it yeah they have garbage
for its garbage well did you ever see
that 60 minutes on how other countries
first world nations do prison no is it
help i'll do it opens with this man
riding his bike around a lake with his
wife and two kids okay and they're
having a picnic and then it goes they
say his name and he's like was
incarcerated for murder two years ago
and ever on Sundays he gets to spend
with his family a free man and this was
and they're like we're not trying to
punish him we're trying to rehabilitate
him and like to take you away from your
family and children they do that but
only six out of seven days a week and
like if you are well behaved you can
spend Sunday with your fam that sounds
like if you murder someone you get like
a sweet vacay
no wife are we he's still he's still in
prison yeah but they're just trying to
help them you know as opposed to like
making him worse it's just that our
system is so screwed our system was set
up on a lot of oppression and anger not
not just not not just our prison I think
just our the United States it seems like
you know it was set up in a ver like the
people escape to be free and then the
instantly created a new form of like
yeah mental oppression and anger it's
just it's a weird thing where you
familiar with Catholicism because I
heard of I mean that's like if I feel
like all of our laws came from that base
or you know it's all just like we're
gonna shame you and guilt you and make
you feel terrible at all times is there
a second piece of cake yes yes there is
I officially became an uncle on son
somebody's a big boy almost huh Punk it
up Oh get up with it I'm gonna hunk it
up that's my new TV show it's going to
be called unk dup uh I was gonna build
one it's gonna be uncle's drinking a
bunch of Miller Lite listening to
Motorhead and then performing pointless
feats of strength it's gonna be that's
cool pretty awesome there's the kid
involved in this he's all about me aankh
do sponsored by already texted my
brother in his way I'm blurted um blur
Huck Huck Huck humbler tuk-tuk-tuk
Ambler's of it was high-tech hawk how
are you um I already texted my brother's
wife and was like I don't know if you
know it's been i'm pretty tired already
being an uncle like yeah i have to do
all that listening and like that parents
have it easy they just have to raise the
kid i gotta be I gotta be cool uncle
role model all the time house kid yeah
can you just send them the the just the
soundbite of Trump constantly talking
positive about babies then going out I'm
sorry get the baby out why would you
think and just like just you know that's
kind of gonna be me when the babies and
I'm when you come to visit versatile oh
that's cute okay can you get the baby
out of the room that lets party the way
did that did he actually do that yeah
yeah you get a big baby out of his
speech are you look I don't support from
I'm not voting for Trump this is what I
saw this how Costas stirs it up though
he's like I don't think he's as bad as
do it I do think every time I check
Twitter's trending it's some outlandish
thing Trump did and then you click it
and you read it actually and it's not
that outlandish so I just wonder like
every time a a trump supporter sees that
stuff it just makes them believe in
Trump more correct yeah doesn't help at
all I because he really is right I'm not
voting for Trump money's an idiot no by
the media the media helped him along the
way helped some more or less happy
really think I'm a racist Trump said
that and you read what he said you're
like oh that's stupid that he said that
but I wouldn't call it like within Heil
Hitler right but you have to put in
perspective it's like he's entertaining
and should stay in the entertainment
world correct and stay out of the
political library that's the difference
it's just like I don't just go I'm the
WWE could enter the ww it's refreshing
that someone is shooting off the hip but
that person should be the fun uncle the
cousin that drank too much like the
family reunion shouldn't be the present
than these days look that whole thing
spiral out of control and as I said to
my wife over and over and over again you
you reap what you sow and that that
world has created this and and he yeah I
think the whole thing kind of happened a
little bit on accident but kind of on
purpose because it was created that way
yeah but whatever I think it'll all come
out in the wash but still it's just the
fact that it has gotten this far is just
my mom it's mind-boggling I I'll I never
would have thought he'd be this far and
if if he becomes president is gonna be
crazy crazy stuff man I think I I do
subscribe whatever else thinks that
either he's gonna bail beforehand or
he's gonna bail afterwards even though
he is he looks like he's believing all
this I think at some point every human
being has to realize when they're in
over their head almost how would he bail
why would he bail before well he's gonna
set up to do so if you bail out if for
September first then the party can
squeeze other candidates on the ballot
in certain states they're gonna lose no
matter what if this happened which will
still be as you think Russian of he
would
party at this point but if he waits till
after if he doesn't on the second they
have no chance and that it then she'll
run on a boat guy is gonna go all the
way and in and try to win I I mean of
course we want that dim to bail but
there's no chance I think he will only
because to me I just look at this is
brand building yeah it's just more money
in his pocket even even if he loses I
mean if ya guys and forty-nine percent
of America votes for him that's
forty-nine percent of the people who
invest in venture Trump's whatever the
[ __ ] all right i % we need to ship to an
island yes fire well some of those
people are just like they just they
don't pay attention there's no party
line they don't care it's like they're
not really it's there there's a small
segment in like in anything anything
that gets really extreme and obviously
you see those you know being posted
online all the time hee hee people that
are like that like Trump are responding
to people they hate political
correctness yes and I live in I'm from
Michigan you guys I know you Illinois I
don't know where your forgot wisco right
okay you know we all know nice to be
with midwest people it there's a whole
there's a different system of belief
over there that's like they hate this pc
world and here in LA you canna hate it
but you like you're just forced interact
with so many different types of people
and it's like you can't it just doesn't
work it doesn't but like they're just
responding to him shooting off the hip
they're just responding to that well
that I agree I agree in the sense that I
don't think yeah they're responding
shooting off the hip and and people
might hate the pc world but like there's
also certain things that you have to
evolve sure and and I don't care where
you live you should evolve as well they
read it and and I unless you're over 80
and your Clint Eastwood and now you have
not a value of and I like tell clint
eastwood comes out Bryon's like all now
he's saying this i hope there's not a
scandal like there's a joke oh I was
like willing everyone Emily cause we
started getting older and he sort of
speaking up it was sort of getting mad
at him for speaking up because I think
you know I think you get to a certain
age you're like [ __ ] I've earned it
i'm gonna say where the [ __ ] I'm on I'm
on the back nine my father is I mean
that he's taking that approach since the
age of 60 like you know just openly he's
like that those are bad parents over
they're at a restaurant I'm like that
that everyone can hear you including the
parent and it just stopped you know they
are they are okay great dad but he
doesn't give a [ __ ] yeah you get to it
gives I don't I don't give a [ __ ] age
and that and and so be it yeah I know I
don't know who wrote but he's like
calling everyone [ __ ] generation or
whatever he was saying I don't know if
it was was either deal I Ellsberg yeah
or uh i think it was eli old brick I
gotta love or well anyway but the post
was [ __ ] [ __ ] generation the hardest
job Clint Eastwood ever had was being
the mayor of Carmel like what does he
think he's been an actor forever like
what is he I mean how hardcore is he
what is he talking well people they're
not out chopping down [ __ ] trees and
like moving boulders and he's not a
prison guard he's not he's a [ __ ]
actor every person always talks about
you know it used to be better when the
good life right it's subjective though
sure yes life is subjective I didn't
live your life I don't know what makes a
good life tennis baby Tennyson if I are
done what I'm saying is like it's so
subjective when people are like I who is
so much better back in the 60s for some
people yeah and then there are other
people there like it was [ __ ]
horrible was better the fire hoses was
that better for people was that well but
I understand everyone a reference it was
better for them it was but goes back to
the evolution thing it's like I'm you
know everybody has to move forward stop
fearing any skin color that is a tad bit
darker than yours or you know somebody
that's from China or you mean like
there's always some reason to fear
somebody else from somewhere else when
they don't look like you but the the
fear is all I mean for the most part
it's it's mental it's in your head you
know I mean it's in your head it's like
yes this is why into the movie
Independence Day really sums it all guys
and they gave aliens do attack we are
gonna have to come together yeah no
matter what you know I think about that
Carter troopers gonna cost ya exactly if
it's giant ants coming to attack you
stranger things oh I liked I haven't
gone into it yet I am going to i liked
it i'm going but you know here's the
thing with that she if you like eighties
movies and you want to feel a tad bit
nostalgic about it you're gonna be
hooked immediately like I'm immediately
you know that was my complaint with the
wedding singer everyone said the wedding
singer was so good
and I was like it's not good it's just a
tease stuff and we were reminded us of
being a tease I like the wedding singer
they do it's a funny movie yeah yeah I
gotta go what would I I did dislike it
was just like oh cool they got they got
the t-shirt right the guy's song right
what do you think comedic Lee obviously
you know it you've been successful or
the comedy but everybody has influences
in reference points for their own
personal sure tastes last decade what
would you classify as a comedy that you
believe actually holds it its own and is
just a what you would classify as a
great comedy a great comedy a TV show i
would i would assume no movie Oh a movie
yeah my guy we can like none of us can
reference it all stripes Caddyshack
whatever but in the last decade since
the 2000s or whatever what would you
classify as a a home run that people
were reference for the next 30 I mean
one of my favorite clips that I still
will go to a couple times a month it on
YouTube is Will Ferrell and Hank
anchorman saying milk was a bad choice
that's like hot out so high so it was a
bad choice and I saw that movie in the
theater and thought it was okay but it
just it has definitely aged well it has
eight anchorman it really is aged well
best thing anchorman did was because I
was hooked with the first [ __ ] shot
of him and that mustache shows like I'm
seeing this [ __ ] yeah like I was in
yeah but then they I watched the preview
in the preview the trailer whatever was
there shown on TV was this [ __ ] like
two minutes of just pure comedy and I
was like did I just see the whole funny
right there in that trailer and then I
went in the first five minutes of the
movie is every commercial that they ran
and then the movie starts right so you
only go you only see that [ __ ] the first
couple minutes thank you oh come look at
how good-looking I am Scott Scott Scott
they do all that [ __ ] right up top and
then the only starts and then his
character is there and it you it's I
laughed my ass off it's a funny movie
along came polly is a very funny movie I
Megerian
didn't expect you to say that I didn't
uh I think it just it's it's just I
think it was underrated at the time I
think it's very very funny you don't see
it very often now did you ever see that
we're them are the millers yeah it's
funny i love that out in fighting
Sudeikis is really funny there's almost
like a UH there's almost the opposite of
anchorman 2 it's like don't push the
comedy that hard and if it really is
just funny like comedy fans will find it
and love it but we are the mill I don't
remember them advertising like I'm help
anchorman 2 pissed everybody off cuz
like the the the promos for it were I
mean it was everywhere like it was so
annoying it was soda and then you see
the movie it wasn't that good I mean
I'll and zoolander to me the original
holds up I know I'm probably saying
popular comedy movies but I feel like
I'm talking I think those are those do
with withstand the test of time I mean
one that doesn't withstand the test of
time that's a maybe there's a lot but I
can't think of one right now soul man so
I don't think that stands it's not a
comedy I mean now you watch Top Gun now
you think it was a comedy you know and
you're like I can't believe we ever
thought this was sweet at one point they
showed the same dog fight sequence like
for the fifth time feel like they only
bought like three clips from the airport
chef Aaron just kept tearing the same
place tease out at all it's starting to
look like a pattern how did i not think
how did I take this movie seriously
because then I saw iron eagle in your
like Top Gun is better yes yeah I guess
there's always a point of reference
right yeah i'm cha goon have you seen
goon that's a yes funny it's only really
villain a movie obviously would never be
hugely successful cuz it's it's it's is
a sub par yeah yeah yeah but what's
really well that was like a
straight-to-dvd yeah yeah j bhushan l
wrote that movie is a funny movie yeah I
would agree um and I'm trying to think
of um I thought bridesmaids was one of
those movies thanks mates definitely is
what are you didn't I just don't think
women are funny bridesmaids is great
bridesmaids was fantastic it was just
one of those things like me and Brian
saw it in a theater and we didn't we
didn't know anything there was no go
free there was no expectation I didn't
seen a trailer I was like I like Kristen
Wiig she's funny she's so fun yeah
and golden blaze that kind of you know
who's a flawed character what jon Hamm's
best roles to ya when he drives all
right he's like like you used me you
know i saw yeah that movie was uh was
really fun i think that one would
definitely hold the test so what I just
I just water's not a Lamia old Oh Hot
Tub Time Machine 2 I don't know if any
way I haven't I haven't I have but I
watched it the other day and it it's as
good as the first one yeah I thought it
was really does funny the hardest I've
ever laughed in a movie theater who any
time in my life I mean I I truly fell
out of the chair and you've seen so many
bad copies of this scene since but when
will ferrell shot himself in the neck
with the dart oh yeah and yes load the
sound down his I'm rule and I mean
you've seen that a bunch now everyone's
been shot with a dart they slowed the
sound down that that had me falling over
in both but I guess both I do like will
ferrell a lot but that scene alone was
just like uh Jerry did that Miss venture
to with the DS like five guards in you
may or whatever was too that's true
that's true maybe just I really have a
thing for darts yeah like a bit dark
humor got that will Ferrell just the
darts ago yeah i was i was a bomb behind
arts and welfare Truman what Ace Ventura
to that was before old-school always
that old school that he got on the neck
yeah oh man I don't remember them
slowing the sound down in they didn't
you just said he slowed himself down
food a little a little a little seat
little little tidbit that you guys
probably don't know but i did a reality
version old school oh yeah for MTV yeah
did you yeah to promote oh the movie old
school they sent me down to Long Beach
with a couple other guys and that's
somebody you know Scotty Ward was was
part of that all right and go stay we
spent a weekend in a frat house no way
oh yeah that on the Hollywood anonymous
facebook page yeah to this I don't see
the thing is I don't think I can pull I
tried posting some the other day that I
made and Facebook went no and then it
said if you truly if you're truly going
to post this and it's all your property
then you need to give us your phone
number your mailing address
this [ __ ] and I was like well then you
know what I don't know why you need my
[ __ ] home address to post something
on Facebook and as like you know what
[ __ ] it back to youtube I go did you see
that there is a picture of uh Zuckerberg
in his office recently and he had tape
over the webcam and it was like you to
zoom in to see that but like computer
nerds went like nuts like here's here's
Facebook's creator using it for is
entrusting his webcam and it's like why
do any of us not have tape on our way up
no there's no to that as a tooth it was
the man that is gonna be some sweet beat
off face are gonna get out of here but
imagine they can get your beat off face
or beat off video and now they [ __ ]
reach out to you and say give us a
thousand dollars or we're gonna upload
your future well you know what then
they'd be uploading everybody I go that
I go well enjoy that Facebook has been
nice knowing you everybody but this is
what I look like when a beat off
unfortunately they would at this point
there is no such thing as a pure human
being correct so it's like if you want
to start playing that game they just
gotta say those agency is gone when the
internet the internet was invented in
like nineteen eighty-three that's what
the last day decent time ever people
like and then they found the internet
and any guy was like I'm decent I'm like
let me see your last hundred internet
searches like I yeah and that's the
thing it's like thinking about this as
you your plan on having kids eventually
I don't know you know that that the
thing is is we're so over exposed online
I mean imagine trying to raise a kid and
trying to tell them what they can and
cannot do when they can just pull up
some [ __ ] that you've done yeah online
and go really you're gonna really naked
mom upside down cake stand so really i
I'm I'm the bad person here right like
you almost kind of lose that because our
parents I knew nothing about my mom and
dad like they presented such a great
threshold a very dirty had seven
pictures yeah that was it two of them
were like faded out like their wedding
picture you know that was it there's no
pictures everything else was was with
stories so there was no fact-checking
correct so whatever they told you that's
all you knew about direct you know
nothing about control the story yes and
enhance the power right and influence in
the house yeah that's what I'm saying
it's like the people like us we've lost
it all because we just share everything
we're we're full on shares but it's it's
gonna come back to bite a lot of people
indefinitely and it's also going to be
embarrassing for your kids when you're
like hey man I saw a video your dad
making some students sketch group or
something yeah my dad's an idiot I
thought first thing as your daddy and I
oh my god who's he think he is you [ __ ]
I think there's someone they like like
Mike Amanda Bynes I don't know what kids
think is funny anymore my dad's funnier
than your dad no he's not look at this
video of him and got two thousand six
years on improv team yeah he's terrible
yeah yeah my mom says your dad is a
loser cuz they were an improper together
other thing the harassment that a cake
and face because of what your parents
want to do if millennial kids will be as
sharing you know like like we're sharing
a lot kind of I i I'm a little weird
about sharing I don't like talking about
you know pick and choose your pick and
choose what Millennials seem like it's
just everything is out there likes
everything is that you know is it or
they create their own narrative I'm not
sure I like that's the titles I think
javi yeah maybe and they know how to say
know how to create the narrative and so
maybe they're not sharing what you think
that they you know I don't know I love I
had that I have this friend lives in
newport beach in and a girlfriend and
another friend of my um uh one of my
wife's friends was like sounds like
jessica is having so is having like such
a great life in Newport Beach and I was
like you talk to her you know and she's
like no like her Facebook is like like
yeah cuz she posted it four teams of her
having fun yeah I should mean no like
her boyfriend got hit by a [ __ ] car
is like that she's not posting that
picture that doesn't go on [ __ ] oh
yeah it's like it does do it does what
does warp your yeah worship sense of
what if you buy into it works your sense
of other people but then like you said
some people do also would I rather see
40 pictures of someone I don't know
having fun or work host about someone
who just got taken off a breathing too
but now correct like yeah [ __ ] yeah you
know yeah speaking of that so you're
from michigan speaking oh wait I wanted
to tell I was there more good news yeah
well no but I what you were talking
about the hardest level holla theatre
okay that was that yeah that was that I
wanted I want to go back to that for a
quick second because when I was in
eighth grade uh I just why we all this
all comes around but I was in eighth
grade I went on
double date with my friend Glenn and
then these two girls that you first ever
shake right Hattie I think it was like
right around the time that I thought
that I I would wear cologne boob jobs
were starting well dude I was so awkward
man what a dating that's gotta be all
cuz I'm just curious I parent my mom
drove us to the moon a quarter and what
if I was like I stole the car now but my
friend serve 14 years in person he's
just getting out now just cuz we with
the swing of commuting sentences Clinton
got you out of that we we went saw naked
gun and on this date and I had never
seen it before and they had never seen
it and the movie started and then he
does the thing where he gets off the
plane the guys like Frank they're not
here for you weird al yankovic is on the
playa I started laughing super hard at
that point and I and and then the girl
was with was like hey I through the
bathroom I was like okay and I'll and
she her and her friend never they left
and never came back it was funny little
time it's a date then though what's a
[ __ ] right was a buddy sat in that
theater and I was crying I everything
that happened that movie had me in
hysterics dude it was the funniest thing
I'd ever seen on a big screen at that he
he I mean [ __ ] gun awesome there's
another great YouTube clip that I go to
sometimes just to make me laugh and it's
it's leslie nielsen died and i forget
the movie it was police quite a movie or
TV blue squad was sorted as a TV show
started as a TV show again we was was uh
naked gun what else from police okay
whatever it whatever this was he walks
in a room he says hello to this man at
the desk and the Mantha desk says uh who
are you how did you get in here unless
Nielsen says I'm a locksmith and I'm a
locksmith and it is is it is the funny i
think even out of youtube its greatest
comedy line of all time and i don't know
i would love to know more about like who
wrote it and what movie I came from but
it is just the brothers man they were
firing all cylinders got it fun well you
gotta think I mean airplane the first
time you saw airplane I mean I didn't
see in the theater I saw it on but I
don't that stands up I think I think
you're the credit it deserves but I I
try to watch it recently and it could
for the time though but for the time
no unbelievable everyone was closer that
stuff everywhere you can kind of put
your uncle hat on sure you can that
movie holds up when you can do that
easily I'm wearing right now guys call
me uncle john from now on yeah um
Luciana hope Huck that's a nice name was
that that was your name oh that's what I
want you guys to climb from now oh no
that's the name of my niece great so you
guys want to send money or anything I'll
get that people are there's a funny name
like you would never name despair yeah
you never hear me hi Billy despair
Johnson are we sure let's Google despair
tuck and see if well we probably come on
you like that posted by you posted by
everyone in your family that's when they
are like oh that's when you realize well
how they really feel about I don't want
to say hope is a funny name it's a
beautiful name but you know it's it's an
optimistic if you ever post you never
give someone a pessimist the right I
think it gives do you believe in that
theory that like the name actually gives
you a better chance of the same naggy
despair Swami is the fast and that whole
ever existed his name definitely made
him faster there's a bunch of wide
receivers whose last name our hands
there's a bunch there's all dude for
sure the UM but even the first name well
yeah I like do you think if you're uh
name was not Mike yeah if it was like I
don't know real great second server
money ya nah uh yeah IIIi think your
name has a lot to do with the
personality that you fall interesting to
me I I don't disagree i guess it is
interesting yeah I think it does I mean
I I I used to tell a joke about being
named Michael back when we don't have
cell phones you would always have to
call someone and say who like you
couldn't just say it's Michael you have
to get Michael Kosta I met chicas
because there's so many michaels right
most of my life I felt like I've had to
like usual call me pasta or call you
know I was the guy you know but if your
name is Asha fonte you know you're not
like a chiffon tape and the remember we
met at no I
forget a chiffon tank I got it so did
you go through a phase where you're kind
of bum that you felt like a generic name
did that bother you i know there's that
whole thing when you're a kid you're
like I wish that you know I member
wishes I remember like like not
necessarily loving my name and then this
this is just typical child and stupid
brain of mine when I realized that
Michael Jordan that Michael that his
name had the same amount of letters in
his first name as my name I was like
that's cool now as I got older I was
like you just had the same name like
that's why you gotta I was like he has
that number is seven or eight whatever
the [ __ ] it is and I was like so once I
realized that there was other cool
people named Michael you know but it it
is a generic it is a German consider
your middle name well my middle name is
another thing that makes people laugh
although it's my grandfather's name is
Burt so I couldn't really go with Burt
usually have you thought about it you're
like no it's not I mean do we know any
births pressure that's it Bert Kreischer
and maybe Bert Haas at the zanies you
gotta favorite of many people yeah uh
that's that's a man many birds eat all
those turtles I burped borth uh from
Illinois that I know an Ernie and Bert
so did you feel like everyone to ya know
like an old person set with my name I
just thought it was an art I thought it
was a generic name I used to be upset
about Brian and my middle name was
Patrick and then I thought maybe I could
go at Patrick and I thought Patrick but
then you really if you're gonna switch
your name you gotta go full force
otherwise they're gonna they're gonna do
you think trolls are bad on the internet
yeah you trolls are just they they
existed in middle school so it's like
that's so you would really has no I
Hammond and ha you gotta go no I I have
a fine name happy with my name and most
people who know me call me call me Kosta
anyways the biggest challenge with my
name is everyone thinks it's spelled
with the sea you know like was costco
like I guess or they go Oh like like Bob
Costas no because he has an S in the end
and it starts with a see so not not like
that was that keen and then he just
introduced you someone from a different
statement walked away yeah you know this
guy's from Indiana by i'm not i'm not
from okay I know what you're doing never
mind Keynes a classic for that the
introduction and that happen yeah
sinner do when he wants to leave he
doesn't say I'm out what he'll do is
back John you know and a god that's a
guy John you're from Barcelona call you
from Michigan right guys probably tigers
cubs they just walked off and you're
like there was no tie in there you
didn't and you realize it's too late
he's around two people say some facts
about him and then leave my gum hey
you're tall you're tall you're from
michigan you're from Illinois I'm
Michigan did you love growing up in
Michigan yeah i did uh we're at mission
we're in ann arbor michigan so it's very
easy to be a michigan sports fan uh is
it rabbit the is it football and
basketball i wouldn't say rat I thought
so at the time you know and then you go
to like Ohio LSU Columbus and you see
that beat Michigan is a great school and
most Ann Arbor is very pretentious it's
all of my parents friends not my parents
were like PhD and that you know those
sit around and talk about like if the
electoral college is still relevant you
know as a kid you're like what the [ __ ]
that's talking about uh and you know so
it was a good but but but Midwest is a
great place to grow up we had a great
yard we had kids riding their bikes
everywhere I mean I didn't have a bike
lock ever you know you just threw your
bike whatever and dad to get these bikes
off the lawn and so I was just a great
safe place to grow up um eight months of
winter sucked seven months of gray
sucked uh what-what winter only sucked
as you after you got to a certain age
yet that doesn't say there's no as I got
yeah there's the reason why because
winter to a kid is days off from school
yeah sledding skating is yes great yeah
yeah when it's an adult it's scraping
windows yeah shoveling driveways it's
everything about it breaking down car
sliding down the on the on the Black
Death like it's just everything changes
then you're like [ __ ] this I thought it
was cool that you could put your beer
outside yeah it would stay like that on
my tennis team an Illinois like these
call these kids come up from Miami and
they'll be like we don't nobody space
with a beer and it's like idiot we have
all the space yeah yeah we can't buy an
open your door for this is no bank yet
we're fine yeah this yet you could put
stuff in your outside and no one
whatever well while my mom was fine
old Miller light cans for my brother's
bachelor party because we have to that
all I did that I just shoved them all in
this snow bank right outside the front
the thaw happened that it's like this is
like that is like I've beer down there
my god neighbor's cat john's party out
six months ago frozen condom someone's
[ __ ] yeah party yeah now so you so you
and your youth was uh mostly sports
driven and comedy by the sports you know
I always wrote jokes which was weird i
have like journals of in second grade i
have jokes you really like what what
inspired that though um I I love
Saturday Night Live okay um and my
family was a teasing family like we
never we never said uh you just want to
turn off your cell phone or there it is
I don't know where it is I couldn't find
earlier could call no one will call me
for nine days and whenever I record a
podcast the doorbell rings the phone
goes off yeah like the kilometer rings
oh really like what yeah we've given up
we just let it be a part of the show at
this point I like I like you gonna do
something about that or you know we let
it ring pretend it's not happening the
difference between this and professional
radio this is professional we got mic
stands was once a year I do a podcast
with mic stands this is excited I have a
whole radio background I can't help oh
my god you know what the show should be
called how many times will bright when
will Brian maybe the radio back I
mentioned it like three times not every
show you've mentioned every show for the
last like five or six show well I had no
choice cuz you brought it up well what
happened what is the radio background
man you listen to radio in the
background or you are you / do a video
on when I vacuumed Oh radio background
oh you've never bought the defense check
i was waiting for someone else you call
me out on it so you talked about the
radio stations all right fine whatever I
never Midwest members and can't turn the
radio on listen to the snow days
disciplines yellow at the school ok
Washington County Washington County and
be like you know they go down today yes
oh love that grade school is never an
issue for me because the school is right
across the street so I could cancel it
like I think maybe twice my life i but
but there are a lot of other kids just
across the street or was it like me a
lot of us walked but
not really right across when I worked in
radio we never actually read the issue
nazo to school what do they do now they
don't do they I don't say internet or
overall trouble calls anymore just text
messages yet messages it's all alerts
well like lat was it last year whenever
the was with the the bottom of the bomb
threat yeah all USD shutdown of them it
was like a patent and LA yeah they did
discriminate obviously they go to the
news but not every wake so I don't want
to do is in the morning so there's
robocall there like so many there's no
way you're missing it they send it
through everything out yeah I get all my
news off a Twitter now a lot of it
anyway I wait for my neighbor to knock
on the door and say something's going
even though he has no kids he's like hey
Charlie he's gonna knock soon cuz I
parked right in front just favorite dick
did you really yeah anyway so you so
silly out there now but Brian Brian
Brian made me kind of feel like it was
okay that I parks there well because
it's fine I mean he'll come over it's
fine i'll come over but it's fine like
one of those though because i felt if I
didn't kiss John gets so angry about it
yeah well I just understand what his
beef is neither day well it's a parking
spot yeah that he doesn't own to what's
up so we're allowed to park yeah correct
understand and the shade it was the only
[ __ ] of their that's why it's like 90
degrees outside the shade I was very
passive-aggressive I apologize so so
writing jokes oh you're watching
Saturday live in second grade which is
interesting because you would think your
parents be like that's not really
appropriate as they had to stop letting
me watch it cuz I couldn't I couldn't
fall asleep uh but what else is funny
about it is I never once wanted to do
sketch which was a sketch show yeah I
always loved stand up so I don't really
get maybe it was just like it i think
the way laughs the way it made me feel I
liked you know you obviously were
familiar with stand up as well if you're
writing jokes so you knew sure I would
write what I thought were funny things
and then my mom used to do this thing
this is so like great mom thing but
every night not every night but most the
night she would like tuck me in and she
would go to tell me something you're
that you're happy for you know tell me
something and I forgot the other ones
but she did usually every night say did
you know tell me something you laughed
at today and I can I can always remember
like it was quick what a in some weird
way that influenced me yeah right you
know it's also smart because usually
parents like
what happened in school today and your
answer is going to be nothing or someone
fell and everyone laughed like that's it
was like did you do something to help
somebody today and we know these are all
wonderful things and by the way I never
helped anybody now to that so i don't i
don't know like this certainly didn't
influence me but I mean I don't know she
was social worker and that without
people by writing your comedy area
you're Joe Perry guy like us people need
to laugh the first live concert I ever
went to his mix again no sensible my mom
took me was [ __ ] Dennis Miller I mean
I was 12 and I loved Dennis Miller I can
i can still while he was doing he was
doing the news on us and el baile news
and i just love i love the confidence
yeah i love the air going squab yeah i
love the hair captain Harry do you know
I still don't know any of his references
you know he would do like something on
the you know Iran can't contra do
whatever the [ __ ] it was a night and I
we have no clue what he was talking
about real Ollie north on my right big
boy DB Cooper walking up like what do I
have no idea was talking about I just
heard him do a rant on XM and i was i
was driving i wrote down the reference
like i need to google all of this i
don't know but i just made me laugh and
that the confidence of that reference
and when you did learn the reference it
was right like it was funny you know
yeah so so your mom actually encouraged
you in some ways you continue to like
she saw chavez he saw that i enjoyed it
so enjoyed it versus going on i knock it
off go do your math or whatever yeah she
I mean my mom took me to see Dennis
Miller for the first time I used to love
she's took me to see Cosby a couple
times oh yeah that's rough he gave her a
couple quaaludes and yeah man no but uh
so there was some encouraging there but
you were writing these jokes and but so
here's the thing yeah it's one thing to
write the jokes it's one thing to
believe that you're funny but were you
funny meaning that like the people you
hung out with either annoyed by you over
to where they are forgetting a guy never
forget that you're funny because you're
in comedy all the time and and every way
like some the other day I went and did
something non comedy related was at a
friend's party and I had like a cocktail
and I was talking my friend I
i made like people laugh a couple times
and i literally turning my friend i was
like i forgot that was funny yeah like I
forgot that like yeah because I was I
was the kid that was funny and it but
but now I don't I'm like does that gone
then you go to interact with normal
people like no I'm some funnier than
these people do you find that one that
people actually genuinely get excited
when they when they know that they're
that you're there and that your
professional comedian in there because
they live in a world where whatever the
hell they're doing is just not a lot of
that or lease is the one guy that thinks
he's funny but they get more excited
when somebody actually does that for a
living and sure and it 100 question say
then isn't it the most uncut goes from
being like oh that's nice to being the
most uncomfortable no I don't I don't
put the negative spin on what I mean
it's like to state they're just excited
like they're probably they're fascinated
and they're actually happy they're not
trying to make you do dance monkey dance
but they're kind of like they're just
they have this level of like happiness
that happens when we happened last night
guys what do you do and I go I'm a
stand-up comedian he goes no for real
and he was he he was pumped and I was
like okay I know the next question is
like uh you know do you love dane cook
or whatever and so I I moved on but it
is nice it is nice that they're excited
about it um but I was the kid more in
school that when I would be gone for the
day and I would come back the teacher
would go we got so much done you know
mr. class clown but it was like there
was always a server there was always a
comment there was always a you know like
am i right or something yeah that's what
she said everybody yeah I probably
thought that's what she said was really
funny ya know I I was the same I know
tigra talking about i was i was
disruptive all the way through college
yeah there are teachers that would would
hate to see me still to this day because
i was and i was never a dick well I was
but not a dick to them I would dick
because I was just disruptive right I
was just trying to always was isn't that
a comics job to disrupt things like wow
in hindsight yes yeah but you know I had
I had a librarian in grade school miss
your own personal one no yeah man we had
a butler and a librarian
the other in the schools across the
street but this lady mrs. Cornell I
can't imagine she would still be alive
today but if she is hope she's listen I
seriously doubt she listened to the
podcast but she told me uh um she's
actually gonna draw pictures for us no
that's to the p.o box one not she she
told me when I was doing something in
the lab with our classes in the library
and I was just being obnoxious you know
what I mean I was just taking it too far
yeah yeah and she kind of just casually
said to me she's like you know there's a
fine line between like funny and then
annoying yeah that's but you know what
and I by and I was like I thought
watches it you don't have to bother
people to be funny yeah and I was like
that's good oh you also learned that
line at the age of 10 yeah well I life
is a little busy for 10 I mean I
remember I used to always trying to be
funny really hurt people's feelings and
now it still happens but a lot less like
I figured out where that yeah and yes
right it still happens but now what in
heck did you get us someone gets overly
offended by something you're like oh you
feeling sock I'm just yeah right right
but back in the day you're right you
would be like right Bucky look at the
teeth in there like hey dick a way i can
like his problem is his teeth in like we
pointed out of Brian's arms all the time
yeah I can take it because I actually um
I like Catholic raise cash you're not
see our date yourself and I feel bad
about that I I did comedy at someone
else's expense not someone but like you
know people that's what you're the
learning curve and some people are like
and again I agree with you like I've
never completely gotten over that you
just do it less and less but everyone's
my people like you need to it not is not
about it someone else expense there you
you are you're funny but when you stick
to like just funny you don't have to
attack somebody will get the lab and you
find yourself doing that kind of thing
like around like we're really close
friends and like Evan then you like it
like I don't know why I would say that
because I'm no better than that dude
like I'm not on my best friend yeah well
but I mean like to about other people
like if you're I'm with my buddy Tim
it's always like look at this guy over
here and then and then I immediately
come back with I can make fun of the way
people look because I'm a model sure
like I mean like right I know that I'm
no better
and all I was doing was trying to get a
laugh out of him and I would have never
done that in front anyone like it's just
you know it it is a punch line you know
in a punch like I think we do if there's
a target the every joke has it it's not
a hug line you know it's like every time
every joke has a target now if you make
it personal and and directed you know
it's like it's easier to to make your
punch line about Trump or like America
you know as opposed to like Steve this
is a lazy left I you know like that is a
tight as it targeted there's also things
that like can't be fixed and you're you
know they're people are born with
certain things or that that's just the
way people are and then there's things
like America yeah that can be fixed yeah
and that should be of the focus yep
something that needs fixing yeah correct
correct so you obviously played sports
tennis was bit was your sport yeah yeah
in in in did you when you were the funny
guy sure I'm all the way through well no
I'm just saying all the way through high
school in a racket was your folk we did
you any good did you ever think that um
I want to pursue a career in show
business or were you realize all I'm
actually talented at tennis and your
focus was like I'm gonna do this yeah I
was a good athlete in all sports just
like it an athletic yeah I brought that
and I said he wanted to make sure we all
know I be on ten it was funny because I
started in middle school started to be
clear that tennis was like the sport and
then when dad realized that that could
maybe mean not paying for college it was
like hey new shoes around and you're not
playing football this year yeah you know
so which fair enough and it but no I
mean he saw my enthusiasm for the sport
it wasn't like he wasn't crazy he did
that because he thought you were the
best at ago now you're gonna play catch
it but I like basketball shut up yeah we
all like winning and I was winning most
at this thing right let's do that thing
yeah um continue the street tennis with
a fireman from tennis growing up was
that the kids that actually were good at
tennis I felt like their lives were just
sucked up with just tennis practice all
the time they were like with my other
friends were good like football and
baseball and basketball they didn't get
sucked away and have a have a guy that
took him to they were all
you know where were you that guy that
has those are team sports they're always
around those other guys and you're like
so you don't feel like you're just
absorbed by a sport because they're
still a social aspect would even amount
of practice though was limited to her
Janissaries without like Tennessee
really always doing tennis but it's she
yes it at that time but now it's it's
changed like if you're a high-level
basketball baseball player your summers
are tied yeah around but yeah so tennis
people specialized very early we didn't
have it we were more middle class I
didn't have like private coaches and all
that stuff um but I would argue that if
I would have done that earlier in my
life that I probably would have been
better late okay i'm a member like when
i was playing professionally and I would
watch some of these kids and I was like
you're just way better at this than me
yeah and maybe it's because I didn't
actually get good until I was 17 the
10,000 hours yeah yeah are just like
also 10,000 focused well coached hours
yeah yeah I was like on the backboard
figuring out by myself which is you can
get you very far but you know I remember
like one time I was watching this guy
serve and I was like you the mechanics
are so perfect every time I serve ice
cream in pain probably because you know
like a pitcher like you can pitch longer
and more efficiently if you have good
mechanics yeah so I never thought
showbiz was an option all I just always
enjoyed comedy i wrote jokes as a way to
get away from tennis because you kind of
eat drink and sleep your obsession and i
would write down things that were funny
and then I got the assistant coaching
job at university of michigan i was
finally in one city ann arbor is this
kind of arts community city did you go
to college I went to university of
illinois for four years graduated from
there when in urbana okay yeah then you
traveled for little traveled for about
three years the area around the world
playing tennis okay yeah I would go in
tennis you back in the day you had facts
how the ITF which was the International
Tennis Federation in London and they
would tell you like are you got into
these tournaments but you don't always
know what like like one of them was in
Jeju Island in South Korea so you had to
like organize that you know and what you
quickly learn is oh great i can get into
that tournament but then i'm going to
have died
riya for nine days right so I was like
it's better to almost not get into the
tournament in like not have gotta go to
Indianapolis and play qualify and maybe
like not lose 35 pounds do not get
dehydrated so it was such a Viking
learning experience I mean you're
sharing hotel rooms with with with other
players yeah you're not getting a sweet
to you you're pissing oh yeah where
you're going I was in Mexico City one
year I shared a hotel room with this
former northwestern player named Alex
Witt and then the draw comes out and I'm
playing him the next day so I'm sly
going to bed like good night opponent
you know and it's like same bed sleeping
with what I get on drugs eh yeah and we
agreed that whoever won because once you
lose your tournaments done you gotta go
on and we agree that whoever like
whoever lost would get to stay in the
hotels and I like that I lost and i'm
going to bed with the guy that beanie
and it's like what the [ __ ] it's not
glamorous it yeah that's sexy it's like
featuring it's it's like feature it's
like featuring there's nothing your ear
you pay you get paid absolute [ __ ] yet I
pay your way there you gotta sometimes
they don't even put you up anymore
Little John husky yeah a real yeah yeah
Little John husk like so did you ever
win a tournament i won only doubles i
want for professional tournaments as a
doubles play i was a much better double
special partner there was a partner in
erotic yeah uh his there's a player
named Raven Klaasen who's now currently
this is what some good character in Game
of Thrones yes Raven Klaasen he's
seeking names yeah he's a South African
he's top 20 in the world in doubles okay
played an australian open final he
almost won the australian open but he
when I quit and by the way in my when
you have my ranking you don't retire you
just stop you quit yeah you know
everyone's like I'm retiring I'm but
you're not retiring sure if you have
three digits in your ranking you are
quitting uh-uh Raven stuck with and it's
been it was 11 years later he made the
Australian Open File I mean it's just %
it was like persistence of the acid and
you know and I was anything if you can
hang on you can hang on
I didn't want to do that for 11 okay I'm
willing to maybe I think put in those
years in comedy but tennis it's just
it's too physically and emotionally
daunting for me so you finally are like
you're burnt out you're tired of doing
this thing get a gig I'm in at home I'm
in ann arbor I'm in the same city
there's open mics I always thought it'd
be fun to watch I used to go watch open
mics and I think a lot of comics started
this way you're never inspired to start
by a great comic because you're like
what a great comic so I could never be
that I could never be that funny and
sometimes you still haven't feel that
way but I was watching who was doing
comedy and you're like the city and I
was like I don't know I can do that I
know I can be better than that [ __ ]
guy and so I signed up I got super drunk
yeah performed ladies are you stealing
Huck stuff right now yes don't like that
story start and I thought I killed and
you know and then how much time do you
have to do like 35 minutes or something
are you know Michigan's a great place to
start i think the Midwest is a lot of
stage time yes no real stakes no there's
no like scout you know the worst is some
of your friends might be like doing with
your life or use did you get suckered
into some competition where I'd invite
everyone I knew who I had to anybody out
to do now were you telling people that
you were gonna go do this open mic or I
will keep it why I wasn't cuz at the
time I was coaching tennis University of
Michigan I was recruiting so you do
methylates yeah I'm not gonna like go
have dinner with some kids parents and
tell them about how I tell fart joke you
know yeah like I'm look we're gonna
build your son into a real man and it's
all about accountability then like that
night I'm like doing ever going down on
a girl on her period what kind of jokes
were you doing when you're first one up
did you did you play to the crowd or did
you actually go to your old notebook and
be like I would tell some of the second
grade secondary costumes mrs. Tracy's
coloring class my first joke I don't
know how to answer that but my first
joke ever I had the host bring me up and
say this next comic has has a black belt
in karate and then I said yeah crotch
karate and then I jumped into the
audience and I pretended to karate chop
people with my dick so what is that is a
goal
that's an act out kind of you're doing a
little which I don't do now so I don't
know i just wrote but i thought was
gonna be funny and so crotch karate back
body crush my flat oh I thought the host
was gonna set it up and it was gonna
crush did so open did people enjoy
getting fake whacked with your day I
don't think so but my next joke was uh
uh I met a girl she's a virgin will she
was a virgin then I go like sigh it was
it was I really responded to arrogance
and self-appreciation and comedy I love
Dennis Miller I loved Don Rickles so you
know when you start you take what you
like and you have no clue how to act how
to execute it like that but I went like
single men stuff together you find your
own for your own but when you do this
first time you have a real job you yeah
a world that you're very very familiar
with your [ __ ] around with this very
unfamiliar world in these bars doing
open mics or whatever uh you do it the
first time obviously you get hammered
yep that night you say to yourself I'm
gonna keep doing this got off stage and
I said to my sister who was drunk too
who's now now two of your silver was
what that's how good my set was my
sister goes over well I gotta clean the
[ __ ] up I said that's the most fun I've
ever had a nice and that's when I kind
of clicked like oh I wrote jokes in
first grade like I've always like why am
I not yeah like shooting sports almost
blurred the real vision in a way cuz it
was I was good at it and when did you
finally get a legitimate gig how long
did it take from the open mics to the
persistence of that before you actually
got a problem gig I remember a car guy
came up to me after cabin mics and was
like do you want to do my club it's got
a wood stage and we were like whoa like
is a good thing and then I did that and
then someone hired me at a bowling alley
for twenty bucks in the basement and I
remember bombing in the basement but you
could hear the strikes above you so it
was this weird dichotomy of like failure
below but then success up there and it
was like as the fun but that was that
was maybe a year in and then until I got
a feature gig another two years maybe
and then I moved out to LA six or seven
years
and I mean so did you to her that were
you a touring I would say I would
because I would been a Midwest feature
at Road act and I sold t-shirts and I
you know I but then I realized that when
I saw kinda who makes it in the Midwest
and I was like I don't think I want that
path yeah sometimes we kind of stays
there right that it just gets not every
comic not every coming to the Midwest is
its way but the headliners in general
the super hacky not funny not original
and I was like I would see that I don't
want that path well that's what I mean
was you have no offense those people I
would classify that as survival comedy
it's a gig a job yeah it's like I know I
know what I can deliver to these clubs
for the two drink minimum or whatever
they want out of it make my paycheck I
know exactly how much money I'm gonna
make this year yeah i Iike it's kinda
sad in some ways could you feel like
they've given up on their whatever was
the drove them or maybe that's as good
as it was I'm going to get for them but
what what for you you're out there and
you're featuring what made you say all
right you know what I'm giving up when I
got ya a stable job where I know I'm
good at something and I'm gonna I'm out
of here I'm Aaron I member uh again
everything seems big at the time now you
look back in your like what that was
that was it was nothing but but i guess
the time it was everything because it
was i entered the washington DC Comedy
Festival doesn't even exist it's
probably it was probably exactly like
these tiny festivals that you know that
but you but it was it felt real they had
a logo you know I entered it I got into
it and I asked my head coach at Michigan
I said hey I know we're playing Indiana
Purdue this weekend Jesus but can I go
do the county fest and he was like are
you out of your [ __ ] mind like you're
an employee of universe Michigan is a
big match in big matches for us and then
when he said no which he should have
said no you a hundred percent I was
furious at up for you know it's like
when your dad's like no you have to do
the job yeah called you exactly uh I
said okay this is my last year coaching
and I'm gonna pursue this and so I was
look on his face when he said well I
told them I didn't tell him right then I
told later he
he's been supportive about come yeah
yeah he was good I didn't want to be at
a tennis college tennis coach college
athletes college coach excuse me you are
so your entire success and failure your
happiness is all reliant on whether or
not 17 year old boy high school students
decide to go to your college and it
never stops every year recruiting sucks
they're there they think they're men
they're boys yeah and they sometimes
decide to go to your school and lots of
times they don't and it [ __ ] sucks
and I wish I would be a college coach if
you could get out of recruiting and
that's what the pros is essentially i
think there's no recruiting that's why a
lot of guys don't want to go back coach
they just I don't want to have to visit
all these houses and talk the same taco
sucks it sucks it sucks and it's you you
get to the point where you're lying you
don't want to lie of course I'm never
gonna leave this job i'ma be here for
your son every single day you know yeah
it's just tough yeah it's tough so
that's cut and then I got in the Aspen
Comedy Festival which was a big thing at
the time while still you know she'll
like a year later now it takes after you
what don't know what year that was 2006
was the last year so the last year that
HBO would did it current was the US
comedy arts festival and had you done i
must other Avenue around then you were a
driver I was a van driver i've got i
drove that festival for like three or
four years i remember i flew in a day
early for some reason and everyone
else's flights got delayed because of
weather so I had four shows booked end
up doing nine I had maybe four and a
half minutes I mean I I could barely
stretch to the five so that festival I
mean they saw the exact same set for me
and you know everywhere but I was green
it was exciting I showcased for the the
buyer with a Booker then in chicago and
i drove a chicago and did it and it just
went well so and then I moved out here
thinking all the everyone told me to
move out here you move out here all
these agents well yeah we can't wait to
see you we got this for you we got this
view I moved out here I called everybody
no one called me back and it was like oh
oh [ __ ] you know did you know about
everyone you decide about no not really
no so were you a cut not even one friend
couch crasher what did you end up doing
else am I
own place and Craig's listed with a gay
Israeli jewelry designer and I used to
always feel guilty calling him an
[ __ ] because he was gay and I was
like no wait a second gay people can be
bad people too yeah this was a bad
person he was a bad [ __ ] know when
you say bad so you going to craigslist
los angeles craigslist living where
everyone a number that I mad person
online what he says he's renting a room
or something like that or needs rubbing
a room and formosa and fountain all
right I walk I i drive my honda civic to
LA from Michigan from Michigan two
things happen within five I park I the
key isn't ready for me or some [ __ ] I've
bike on my car I take the bike off i
lock it to the gate okay I walk down a
Jones Cafe are not Jones formosa cafe
you know I was like heaven and I'm like
I'll get something to eat or whatever
while I'm waiting for this key be me I
walk in I see Andy Dick he grabs my
nipple I've been in LA three minutes
okay three minutes I'm from Michigan I
know he grabs my nipples he says
something like this this kids cute he
had a tea at a tether on his ankle at
the time I'm a tether or like a house
arrest bracelet I don't know I don't
know the difference okay but but this
was there was a black box attack yeah
that's a hot that's a house arrest or a
sober house type in and I guess looking
back people tell me like I guess he's
just go on these [ __ ] benders banders
and would see him everywhere around
Hollywood so I was like holy [ __ ] that's
Annie dick I don't get it I hang out
with or whatever I go back up to my new
apartment the bike that I had locked on
the gate now has someone else's lock on
the bike okay like a different lock has
my lock also but it's a different luck
so I'm like yelling like what happened
this Russian woman comes I'm this
literally like welcome to West Hollywood
she's screaming at me I don't I could
over the course of time I can find out
that she was mad I locked the bike on
her gate uh you know I don't know I'm
like okay can you unlock it she goes no
I'll unlock it when I want online
and I'm like Jesus Christ Jesus but this
is welcome to Hollywood I mean it's like
I had no [ __ ] clue everyone was crazy
of course they're crazy this is a
craigslist go up the guys you know he's
very nice and gay at the time but he's
just a [ __ ] dick and his roaches
everywhere I wake up every morning turn
the lights on and they would all [ __ ]
scatter they'd go into the bathtub they
go into the sink and yeah III spent a
lot of time back in the Midwest when I
first moved here it was it was too tough
you drove back when other side and I
would do like three week runs you know
or work its clubs and now i guess i
guess it was good because i can only
handle that this life for short periods
and i hear people now that move with
their friend and they get an apartment
and I'm like why did I do that why don't
I buddy up with somebody and move here I
mean it was so tough by yourself but
there's but it builds the guy this is
gonna sound clichéd it does build the
character it determines whether or not
you were willing to survive all this
[ __ ] or not yeah air it seems like
we've talked to a lot of people about
this and shared our own experiences that
that's just part of the game if you're
gonna come out here yeah I mean yours is
a little bit funnier than most but but
the point is that you know that's the
kind of [ __ ] you have to put up with if
you want to stay here yeah it's and it
doesn't really ever go away you just
learn how to navigate and you you've you
figure it out you through people through
connecting with people that you trust to
say hey man why did you get a roommate
off of craigslist you know they say let
you go yeah that's a good idea but yeah
it the hardest part of making
quote-unquote making it a comedy isn't
necessarily performing on stage it's um
it's all this other [ __ ] where was the
first gig you did out here I remember um
you know I went to the I went to I think
at the time it was maybe chuckle monkey
is that still a website yes yes jungle
monkey was before yes yes yeah because
that was like now the comedy Bureau or
whatever but it had a list of all the
thing the open mics in the stage is that
this is a book room this is an open mic
you gotta sign up at this time and like
so i would go do some of those i
remember like the first memorable thing
that happened to me
comedy was I went to this comedy store
open mic which it used to be a Sunday
6pm sign up and they would post it seven
who made it now keep in mind i'm not i'm
not like stainless uh arrogantly but i'd
been on live at Gotham which was a
television credit this is when we did
you move out here by the way two
thousand seven eight okay yeah so you'd
already done live 'god don't live at
Gotham and I had done the US Aspen
comedy fest so I had a couple like legit
way more than the people your sign about
yeah most you know what you know I'm not
saying I was funnier but I had a couple
things and that's kind of you learn
means yeah yes yet nothing it doesn't
mean yes out here so I signed up I
didn't make it I was like that sucks but
I'm like let's watch the show and see
who makes it so I'm in the back watching
the show and I'm like okay this is
pretty brutal and then this homeless man
had signed up and at least he appeared
homeless to me and they kept calling his
name and he like he wasn't there but he
was in the bathroom washing his feet in
his body in the bathroom so he signed up
to use the bathroom yeah and he made it
yeah and I was like oh [ __ ] this isn't
this is harder than I thought I thought
I was like at a TV credits sign up you
know the homeless guy who signed up God
and he's like it's probably boom
shakalaka now they look back I'm gonna
say probably had a couple I don't I
don't know if they still survivor on
there there was another guy that had
like a a beard and he had like severe
OCD and he kind of wanted around a grey
haired bearded yeah long hair but
there's a couple there was a guy that
had half a face oh yeah that guy and I
talked about him sometimes on stage um
you know truly was half a face someone
told me that he he tried to kill himself
with a handgun and he went under the
chin and it didn't execute doesn't work
you know why you got to put it in your
mouth but oh let Joe but don't ever put
a gun in your mouth right legally lit
yeah don't ever do this either this is a
bunch of putting the gun sideways to
your eyes I'll people just blow their
eyes off okay you still a lot but don't
even try it no don't you see if you get
it right right all right right so yeah I
mean you so you didn't twenty sell ads
on this below their eyes off you
but you did have so you did not have
representation that was the one thing
that you they and again it back then
just so you know I mean obviously been
coming from the comic store they didn't
accept that the you you can have a rep
call in anyways gonna get you staged
there anyways I mean I would have just
as much luck calling myself and saying I
am I'm Joshua Goldstein which nothing
yeah uh there was a lawyer there was a
lawyer that took a liking to me at the
Aspen fest and to his help Greg Gelman
he made calls and set me up with some
managers okay and i ended up ventually
signing with some people so i probably
didn't need I probably should have gone
through the comedy store in a different
path than the signing up for the open
mic is I knew enough comics and like you
know in my class and Aspen it was like
Kurt Fox TJ Miller Eric Andre you know I
could these were my friends yeah I could
have asked any of them yeah you kind of
show up and wanted to like do it on your
own a little bit well I which is I think
says a lot about you you weren't looking
for handouts or favors I just want bill
to see me on stage and realize how funny
i am who was looking for him now well
right yeah right was the first person
that you did not know when you came out
here that you actually still like me
like when you got out here the first
person like our I kinda like this person
IE p Peter Berman was the first comic
that helped me I don't know if you guys
know Peter Berman he's fantastic and I
haven't seen him in eight years but he
was the only guy that was like call me
when you get out there and I'll try to
help you and he's like I got this for
you I got this for you in and they were
no [ __ ] home runs but it was work and
it was a nice guy reaching out it was
someone to sit in a car with for two
hours and just be like am i a crazy
person and you don't know you're not
this was how it is for me too so he was
he was great um and then tennis always
rears its head you know tennis cuz cuz
it's just as something that isn't comedy
and a couple tennis friends reached out
and all of a sudden I had a community of
people that wasn't comedy while I was
figuring out comedy that really helps
the living part yeah like actually just
going alive yeah it's a socialized hey
do you want to have drinks to tomorrow
like oh my god I would love to have
drinks and right because the comics it's
just like I'll just see with the next
gig and your socializing is all gigs saw
nothing else you know or talking about
gigs we're grabbing a cup of coffee like
that's yeah I gotta go another spot
whatever whatever which is why I like
that's why I like this the Breck
that we do it's like not always a gig
you know we end up sitting around
talking about [ __ ] well to some
extent but you're just want to
understand you you you decided to open a
create like a little gathering a secret
if you were where people can just kind
of just come and socialize cuz a lot of
comics don't get out of the house we
don't get I do they don't or we only
socialize if we're drunk which you know
maiya culpa yeah but it's just a way to
hopefully get out of the house and
connect with humans and just so I is a
man because it doesn't it is something
that like I do need to get out you know
I mean it's like it's not easy man i
don't i'm not a social person anymore I
just don't yeah i'm i'm i'm in a very
weird place with comedy to laugh like I
every I've done a show every night for
the last week and they've all been awful
garbage you know when I was in radio I
didn't wait what I literally I got it I
got a spot last night I got there I was
like yeah I was supposed to be here and
they're like oh ok well I'm ok you can
go on last and do three minutes I was
like okay and I just went home yeah I
just turned around and left well that's
[ __ ] well it was just weird like
it's a three minute I was like I you're
beyond all that what it goes back to
what you're talking about about you
believe that your accruing points yeah
kinda like tennis and you're not yet
sometimes you find out you've accrued
absolutely nothing zero points or
someone will be like hey come to this
show and you get there and I think I've
joked about this on the show one time
where I drove all the way down to San
Diego at two and a half hours from a gig
and it was me my buddy that came with me
and TIG Notaro yeah that was there was
nobody in the bar yeah except for the
guy that book that and it gave me the oh
oh you don't normally last week oh I'm
always that guy oh man last week dude it
was packed in here like uh huh yeah yeah
I guess I'll go again no signed those
things that's part of I know let's see I
feel like but I feel like I've paid
those dudes like I used to go up
anywhere and everywhere I could as many
times a week as I possibly could and
then it stopped being helpful do you
know I mean like I'm trying to grow as
an artist I'm trying to be a better
comedian me rambling through
stories or jokes at told a thousand
times to [ __ ] people who aren't
interested yeah doesn't feel like it's
helping me some of it is you gotta pay
your dues and some of it is we gotta be
smarter yeah and it's what's on me I
mean whoever that person was like you're
not gonna do that club again or what
show you know that person's off the list
we all made the mistake of driving three
hours yet for some j you always do and
then it's like okay don't be the idiot
that keeps doing that yep I thought mini
yeah exactly so but yeah it's yeah so
how did you feel good that I'm sorry no
it's to say but then I get [ __ ] upset
if I don't have any gigs Leonard and
then I'm like well Jesus am i even a
comedian yeah you are Kimmy but that's
like but I just I have I'm just gonna
have to be smarter and only really do
things that I think are gonna allow me
to like if I'm not enjoying myself how
the [ __ ] is the audience going to enjoy
it laughs this is no way it's just
disturbing I mean la's hard because you
won't nothing will happen for a year or
a year and a half or two years and then
one day three things will happen that'll
keep you hanging on okay being an exit
agree years yeah so it's like it
probably would be more beneficial
instead of driving to San Diego or
whatever to go to the comedy store for
an hour you know maybe maybe you can put
up with the [ __ ] networking thing if
you just give yourself an hour yeah like
I always feel like what I really don't
want to go to the improv and just
standard up okay well then go for 20
minutes yeah an idiot you can do 20
minutes yeah always pretend you have to
be somewhere else and you always end up
driving home after doing that and being
like you know I saw that guy I like that
is the always always always full time I
make the effort yeah and go out there
like 20 minutes an hour just like you
said like and for the store for me it's
the traffic in the parking that's
annoying is it is the biggest reason to
not do it all right but then like the
improv it's a little easier to pump but
you're right just go 20 minutes cuz
every time I'm like oh man I saw I
talked to TJ and seen him I'll talk to
so I haven't seen a while thought you
just and you also go and i still hate
that guy yeah I did I never need to see
that duty
but I again yeah but ya know you're I'm
saying this as much to me as I am time I
mean I you know in so but you eventually
um so you kind of do the where was the
UM anantapur not the breaking point
where did everything kind of turnover
where you became the headliner you're
sure got your name on the wall to comedy
show comedy store I mean there's there
are high points here yeah obviously it
out here I mean I would say that I used
the road as my stage time because I
quickly found out that here it was like
unless you unless you're one of five
percent of the comics here that gets
consistent staged I was too hard so I
sacrificed time in LA and I would go on
the road and I've missed some things I
missed some opportunities that were here
in LA I was like I'm sorry I'm trying to
and so then I went to had opportunities
to showcase for Comedy Central and The
Tonight Show I felt like I have really
polished good material so one what
probably the most obvious breaking point
was Hermosa Beach past me so I'm comedy
romantic comedy magic club so I
performed there a lot they give you
these great tapes it's a difficult stage
to get on so I have these great sets i
could send out they liked me they
invited at the time jay leno's Booker
down he liked me that I got on The
Tonight Show and I had a good set that
that's what really moved things forward
yeah then Tommy at The Comedy Store
Mitzi saw your said she loved and then I
got past and again that was all in like
a month I've been here for three years
you know it was like so that helped that
helped a lot um and also though I I for
me it was very important to tape get
good tapes hmm now I don't know you
don't call them tapes but it's still
important yeah get aboard [ __ ] tape
send it out like it it for me it worked
and I think to me audio is more
important than video I think if it needs
to sound really good yeah I think I go
so and what ultimately now that you've
been out here about eight years or
whatever what's the next step for you
like what's the goal what's the endgame
yeah I mean I'd love to host a
television show that you've now you've
gotten I've done some yeah what I be
besides you at the comment section but I
did something before that I was
show I was on foxsports1 show called
crap now goes while that's right that's
when you moved to New York Regis Philbin
yeah yeah I was sweet that was sweet
super fun it was a lot of people it was
six people on the on the panel but it
was a lot of fun Regis was the host we
had amazing guests you know like dr. J
Mike Tyson yeah John McEnroe oh no I was
just like great gets we we had the Fox
name yeah we did a hundred and
seventy-six live television shows I
don't think anybody saw one of them I I
was a few of them because thank you John
I always thought your fun even before I
really knew you and then when I saw you
that show was like oh yeah I guess I
heard he played tennis so I was like
yeah he's a seasoned athletes who were
he's doing in there and then it just it
was funny man I enjoyed it then I saw
you in New York house like hey
congratulations on that you like it's
canceled and I was like that is not your
fault yeah stylistically with your
comedy do you ever feel like when you're
uh doing shows and your meeting other
comics that they're like is this guy
going to be an [ __ ] to me because
you're not you're like we're nicest like
I remember the first time I think I met
you may have been at barney's beanery or
something like that which it but I
wasn't quite sure about you but then you
start talking like oh my god this guys
[ __ ] is I mean you're one nice as you
get your own you're a balanced normal
person so you're you're open to like
let's talk to him for a sec you know oh
and make your own decision right but
some of these like super self-conscious
bitter angry comics like just have
decided based off of a tweet or wood as
they are or that I Shane's a mother or
the I shave and and I'd like to work out
that I'm going to be a [ __ ] to them and
it's that you can't win I'm not trying
to win anybody over but you guys you
know I'm a nice dude uh animal but you
but you maybe they have a nice guy and
you notice that that's something
sometimes based on dude I elastically
they sure know and I again I appreciate
comedy based on arrogance there's
nothing more arrogant to me there's
nothing funnier than arrogance because
we're gonna die anyways yet to think
that you're better than something this
is the point funny because you were all
dead yeah all gonna die so to me that's
what's funny and I can't put a
self-deprecation is great
but it doesn't always work a lot of it's
based on image and how you look at
what's gonna say if you go up there and
you're like a cure I'm so horrible look
ever be like that I mean Neil brain uses
joke about how like the economy's so bad
the banks are gonna lose your money's
like what lose all my $62 and everyone
laughs and I was like [ __ ] you you I
know you don't have 62 now suppose I get
I don't think it does anymore but I'm
like I if I doesn't I've said it to him
I'm like stop doing that joke it's not
it doesn't work for me and that's a bike
as you get you know as people come up
and they get more there but more
notoriety more money those jokes about
your appearance and how shitty your life
is yeah they don't work so you better
offer you better yeah work on making
your precious life the fun life funny
like I remember sign Phil had that joke
about like sitting in coach and they
close the curtain on first class and it
was so funny and it's likely he probably
flies [ __ ] private now yeah is on get
your jokes on Friday yeah hey we're on a
private jet they're out of belvedere
like so when you try to move to the next
part of your career do you find it
because you've obviously you've got the
stand up sure but you need you want
something else now to there's another
carrot does it get how do you how do you
balance that and not get too frustrated
because as you know in this business
you're going up to another level sure
where every opportunity is less and less
you thought it was hard getting stage
time that's even harder to get face time
with general right I mean I don't know
the answer to that at all maybe but for
you how do you deal with it poorly I
mean I mean I I I but you know you can't
but you know you but you pull back on
your history I'm not give it up cuz I
obviously yeah I haven't I don't think
I'll ever give up comedy you know it's a
matter of do i do comedy living in a
house in Michigan that has a yard and a
you know or do I stick with it here and
yeah I don't know I honestly don't know
and I'm not trying to sound pessimistic
but no but it's it's it's such an
interesting time and television because
what is television is it internet is it
you know i watch mostly the internet on
TV Netflix HBO even though those debts
traditional TV it's through the internet
and now there's all these like apps
coming out and and so I want I've always
wanted to host a show I would I would be
very happy with a long term funny
hosting job but guess what probably a
lot of people would be so so that's what
I'm trying to do but you also have that
kind of personality that's like right to
host a show like I'm not saying you're
Jimmy Fallon or anything like that but
the like that affable like all right you
know you're not like like I you know I
don't be probably a little bit much if I
hosted a tent like The Tonight Show who
like take all right yeah I mean I'm
feeling sick of it where it's like a guy
like you come out and be friendly and
make fun of some people and have some
fun I will still think you're genuinely
norm thank you my dad owned a travel
agency and he used to take tours of
people to these geez these trips like
we'd go to Wimbledon and my dad would
bring all the kids and would go to like
the Westminster Dog Show and the
Philadelphia Flower Show and I would sit
in the back of the motor coach and my
dad with all these people that bought
tickets to my dad's event my dad would
grab that stupid motor coach microphone
and you know he always had these
terrible jokes about Philadelphia's
fountain and then and these people would
laugh and I remember like 10 and being
like that looks like fun to me like I
wonder you know you basically just want
to be your [ __ ] dad yeah I want to
sleep with my mom my dad that's all I'm
trying to do not what I mean I saw my
dad till like a tee times a storyteller
when he told stories people listened and
they have like hung out and even then
when they were stories that I weenie my
brother had heard over and over and over
again they were animated there was
little act outs there was Nate like so I
got a different bit of a better punch
line every time and then the specific
names always tell me like the guys he
would be out Donnie slop ski on the
corner wiping his nose on his jacket
like just the weird names that he would
bring up and always like include yeah
yeah but yeah you see that and you see
other people being drawn to that and and
did the attention it gets and you're
like oh okay be cool and also my dad
made fun of himself a lot a lot yeah
that was the butt of most jokes and him
and his buddy would go back and forth
and I kind of that was very Midwest but
I saw that and that's I mean that's
pretty much what my humor is very
somebody it's very self-deprecating yeah
yeah it's funny so for you moving
forward I mean obviously you know for
now
you get to host noah's bagels which is
awesome really don't say the location to
TMZ shop yesterday what the [ __ ] was
that dude I'll we should talk about that
off air but what was that I don't know
but I think I'm gonna be on TMZ sports
okay that's good for his hat pays off
yeah yeah that's good nobody I mean are
you do you see yourself out here as a
very social person or do you see oh is
that what drove you to do the notated to
get I was together I was feeling like I
wasn't doing a good job with that oh
yeah yeah I wasn't um I'm happiest when
I connect with people i think most
people are that way and i was like we
need to do something and I would always
try to do things at night like I'd get
the fight hey comics come over and it
would be like a dude you know or I gotta
show I gotta show I got a show or it was
just it was just tougher and I was like
it's tough to come up with a reason you
can't get a [ __ ] bagel at 11am I mean
unless you're really on set and some
people are great no look if you're but
that's the idea if you're working more
power to you if you're on the road Agel
TV show a commercial something that's
great yeah you get free bagels enjoy
your free bagels and your paycheck yeah
but but like it's nice that if you don't
have anything going on you can still
like and for me it's I'm not gonna lie
it helps that it's I can walk there yeah
of course you know if it was in culver
city it still calm everyone so every
once in a while I would I would I would
probably drive Nicole to work and then
yeah stop by or whatever but I just
getting a little bit older realize like
the the most fun is is hanging out with
people and and the best networking is
always when you're not networking yes
like you always know that guy you play
golf with it's like second hole like so
what do you do I got a guy for you and
you're like that's this is not how we're
gonna do it yeah we're gonna [ __ ]
play golf and then eventually three
years from now maybe we'll be friends
you know like so make it slow and by the
way the bagels thing has already paid
off I've done uh Joe kill gallons
podcast and your pocket I know I just I
just can't see it getting better than
this well it won't unfortunately this is
the highlight for you well that's going
to me it sounds like at least you're
staying level-headed you're very hyper
aware of your of your surroundings your
you still try to do what what what's
your ratio of like in town out of town
like how much do you I'm you know i
should say the the thing I'm most
thankful for is I've had agents
throughout the years that have booked me
and so I get two weekends a month that I
can go on the road and sharpen my skills
and you know John Huck's looking at me
right now like he wants to slice me with
a knife because because I've been there
to where your funny person that should
be on the road and you try to book
yourself and it's [ __ ] hard yeah it's
really [ __ ] hard so I'm very thankful
that and probably my TV stuff is really
the reason why they're keep booking me
on the road because that he'll still
gotta be fun yeah well I think to come
back you can get that first oh he was on
TV and then it's like yeah but who the
[ __ ] cares cuz he sucked yeah then you
gotta be funny you've got to be funny so
for me the road has always been
something that allows me have some money
pay my rent so I do to about two
weekends a month they're all posted on
michael kosta calm and uh yeah they're
not all glamorous but uh and it's easy
to drink too much on the road easy no
easy it's a trap dude and it's not even
for me it's like it just happens in the
hotel room when I'm by myself it happens
anywhere you want it to happen you're
you're you're at a [ __ ] your own
fraternity for the weekend yeah yeah but
you got to be smart about it yeah will
do thanks for coming in thanks guys yeah
I do thanks for being on the show yeah I
appreciate it anything else you want to
pimp or you are you a straight up but
just go to your website never you can
find everything from there I have a
podcast called the worst birthday
podcast which John Huck has been on yeah
and it's a fantastic story yeah I a
friend of mine from college hit me up on
Facebook private messaged me and was
like hey got picked up by a friend today
this is like a week ago she's like I got
picked up by a friend today I jumped in
his car your voice was coming through
the speakers and I was like are you
listening to John hahaha and he goes
yeah this is a podcast I listened to
called the worth worst birthday podcast
or worst birthday ever podcast it was
just tell me your worst birthday and
John's is great i forget what episode it
is but it's it's really funny listen to
also nadine a lot people know this about
john but the day he was born his
grandfather passed away yeah did you
know that no um can I tell you such an
that being is his dad that's you gained
a son lose your father yeah same box
what were they can I tell you that
something pretty morbid uh this so the
day I was born my grandfather died and
the day my brother was born my dad's
best friend our neighbor his father died
weird okay the day my parents were
married my mom's father passed away no
[ __ ] yeah so like tragedy comes after
big celebrations in our family like real
quick like so my brother and his wife
went in last Saturday the thirtieth to
start inducing labor for their baby and
I'm like thinking about it I'm like okay
who's next yeah like my mom isn't way
too good a shape sure he's got a social
life she's out there partying all the
time I she's she's top she's at the top
of her game right now yeah and I'm like
that leaves me exactly so I literally
went to this website that helps you put
out tweets like Times tweets and I set
to tweak to go out at 12 and 12 15 on
the 31st in case I died in my sleep that
night the day would go out yeah I
thought you went to a website where you
could talk about your feelings and said
like that hearing for your queen yeah no
no I literally like what was it social
crowd torture was like Twitter indeed so
what was the tweet then if you died uh
well one was just like a of Tupac yeah
yeah that's it yeah a peace sign hashtag
yeah whatever I was just a picture my
dick oh good check out worst birthday
calm you can listen to John Hawkes it's
really good yeah and it's a funny idea
for podcasting thank you go see Michael
Kosta whenever you can live very funny
you won't be disappointed k poop gets
out next week
and i'm an auntie all right all right
little man congratulations full recap
call back thank you for listening to
Hollywood anonymous don't forget to
follow us on twitter at hollywood and
nany that is short for hollywood
anonymous you can also follow john
individually at John Huck and myself
Brian or when at Brian or went on
Twitter as well both of us can be found
on facebook you can also google us and
contact us directly Hollywood anonymous
guys at gmail.com thank you again so
much for listening and please don't
forget to subscribe